[Music]
so you've had the reason
yeah off camera yes no on camera no yeah
yeah so I haven't I mean like gay people
bisexual trans yeah I love everybody you
love everybody yeah I Believe In Love
Speech you better give me a cheat kiss
okay
[Music]
nice to meet you thank you I'm Nazarene
yeah nice to meet you you too
how are you I'm good good we both asked
a question at the same time I know I am
uh I'm a little hungry are you hungry
yeah I am hungry can you cook
can I cook of course I can cook what can
you cook anything really
um my favorite thing to cook is probably
steak
um with
vegetables or Salad spinach not
necessarily because spinach is actually
not very good for you it's very high in
oxalates which um
it's just an anti-nutrient which means
that you're basically not adding
nutrients you're taking them away when
you eat spinach
who told you that it's a fact that can't
be true it is true it's not good for you
it's a fact based on who who said that
just based on
many studies okay yeah that's why you
kind of get like joint pains and stuff
from Spanish not not just from spinach
like many vegetables have oxalates in
them but yeah okay it's not great for
you but anyway
you look great I'm like I like your
dress thank you thank you very much
ready to you look like you're out on a
date right now well I thought this was a
date this is but we don't have any food
I know yeah it's missing the food
because you are hungry aren't you so
let's imagine let's have an imaginary
date what are we eating right now we're
having no spinach steak so you're eating
you're eating a whole steak a whole
steak
I could eat two steaks really eat a lot
of meat yeah you eat a lot of meat I do
you not eat a lot of meat I mean I
consume a lot of me I don't I don't eat
meat what do you mean you don't eat meat
but you consume it
maybe the terminology the translation
there's probably an error right now but
I understand what you're saying okay
okay so you eat a lot of meat so what do
you do I am a businessman
nice I'm in a lot of different
businesses ah all right businesses okay
you're not going to go into it what do
you want to know nothing really what do
you do
um well I work for a council I put
people into housing if they need housing
like
um usually vulnerable people I put them
into housing I wouldn't move on over
homeless people
um sometimes
um or just people who have like a
massive family and don't have any space
like overcrowding situations for people
that had too much Spanish and the points
don't work and they need a house
you give them home exactly okay
um that's nice I know it's very kind
isn't it yeah does it pay well uh I mean
not as well as I'd like it to but I'm
not really focused on that because I
know that my eventual dream is to have a
family and not work
um so that's what I'm kind of waiting
for
um yeah my dream was to like have a big
house with a field and grow my own food
have like animals and eat them good like
cows because I think we have to
um start providing for ourselves instead
of
relying on supermarkets which can
actually cut us off if we have like a
really tyrannical government one day
which I mean you can kind of see it's
kind of getting technical already isn't
it
are you jabbed no
why not I had a feeling you weren't did
you yeah I think you're saying kind of
coincides with that you want to be a
Trad white traditional wife yeah Farm on
Jabs you know who else is on jab you
um
I like that song what would you date a
job person absolutely not yeah
absolutely it's just a waste of time I
don't want to have children how many
children do you think you can give me as
many as I can have
what's your ideal amount probably like
well at the moment probably about seven
no word of Elia and what are the the
different the genders I don't know
whatever comes whatever comes what about
ideally well I'd like at least one of
each so
so six Sons and one daughter
if that's what happens then yeah I'm not
in control God's in control so that's
great I don't get to choose that that's
great are you a Muslim no I'm a
Christian you're a Christian yeah okay
Jesus all the way
Muslims we respect Jesus there you go
yeah I mean that's fine as long as you
believe in God
because you can't really argue with the
fact there is a God
I don't think so what do you think about
the argument that Jesus is God in
Christianity you see that Jesus is God
at the same time the holy spirit all
this stuff I mean I get that because if
you think about it well you can have
like three droplets of water
and then when you put them all together
they turn into one right so it's not
like an impossible thing for me to think
about I used to kind of find it hard to
get my head around it but
it's not that
um I kind of understand now I don't know
for sure though if I believe that Jesus
is God but I understand that and I I'm
kind of beginning to the more I read the
Bible the more I believe it
um you're pretty smart thanks I mean you
don't know what I do do you you do that
I do the house people I House people but
um in my spare time I am an activist
so I go on the streets and I talk about
the covered vaccine I talk about
um the new odd order Bill Gates
trying to destroy us
um trying to make us eat fake meat and
bugs what do you think about the world
economic forum
I mean they're planning on running the
world aren't they and they probably will
eventually if we allow them to
they're tyrannical they're trying to
make us own nothing and be happy clausch
uh what's your favorite crypto I don't
need no so you've seen like a Bitcoin
type yeah one day one day one day you're
waiting you have to learn about it well
you're an activist so where do you go
and do this stuff everywhere on the tube
on the under have you been attacked by a
Wookie I've been attacked by a of two
people actually yeah would they have
blue hair no they were they were
actually both old
really yeah do they have a mask on no
actually I think one of them did yeah
one of them did why did they attack you
well actually he attacked my friend he
pulled down her sign and then like
punched her a bit and then she punched
him back and then I ran jumped on him
jumped on an old guy
allow it to happen but I also went on
talk TV recently where I exposed Bill
Gates and Flash Schwab and I called them
Psychopaths and murderers and I said
that Bill Gates killed thousands of
children which is true because he did
and then they had to cut me off and
they've reported me to like every single
social media and tried to get my account
removed I'm canceled too so yeah you
know we're in the same boat it was a lot
it was for election misinformation code
with misinformation talking about this
information I mean it's it's
misinformation until it's true the FDA
just did you see what happened now they
just banned the original modern and
Pfizer and they just made this new one
so even the unjab people don't they're
saying don't get it now I mean in the in
the UK you can't even get boosted if you
want if you want one what like because
they realize from it yeah I don't even
know if we can say this like it's it's
because that's true now and the
government's saying that's true but the
policies on social media sites are still
kind of dated so you can actually get
banned for something that the government
is saying because they haven't updated
the misinformation policies yet is that
insane it is insane I think it should be
reinstated because what what are you
about to say nothing
I was listening to you that was great
okay what made you how are you Red
pilled
how am I Red Coach yeah well when
the pandemic happened yeah I had no
choice but to be because I realized
everything wasn't making sense and I
wanted to believe it and I was trying to
understand why people wanted to give
away their rights but I couldn't get it
um and I began to see how
people were so quick to just believe
anything they were told without any real
evidence I went to a hospital and it was
completely empty when we were being told
it was completely full
um then I had friends who died
um well one friend who died from the
okay yeah just say Jan from the job and
um a lot of my friends were having
adverse reactions from it and I was like
thank God I didn't get it there's nobody
that regrets not taking it everybody
regrets taking it but there's nobody
that stayed on jobs like I wish I got it
I know that one person well there is
some fake people who get paid to say it
on TV they are liars but they are and
nobody watches TV like this I mean I'll
watch yours I want to go see that
segment
yes it's very interesting his face is
like hilarious do you like Alex Jones
yeah what do you think about Trump
what do I think about him yeah I think
he's probably the most successful
president that America's ever had great
what do you think about the yay 24
campaign Do You Hear What uh when Kanye
West is running for president I heard of
that yeah what do you think about what
he was saying
um I don't remember what he was saying
but I said I love Hitler oh did he yeah
oh well I don't know what the context
behind that was I don't think it's from
what I've just heard it sounds
a bit weird like I don't I don't think I
would say that personally but it's um
this is birthday today oh Kanye West
birthday oh yeah I heard about that he
was born on 420. that's quite funny
okay who do you think controls the world
at the moment the world economic Forum
but I think actually no
they're I think they are they're losing
power I think no puppets in it I think
the Rockefellers and the Russians yeah
the people the most of them telling them
what to do right the world they're kind
of the face of that for conspiracy
people because I mean they've messed up
with the name World economic Forum
saying things like great reset it was
pretty a lot of people are you owe
nothing and be happy yeah they messed up
with a lot of quotes and they lost
credibility and not a lot of countries
have actually signed up to uh to join
really they're messing up the
Netherlands quite a bit they're like
getting rid of farms but other than that
they don't have as much power as it
seems so I wouldn't say that they're all
the way at the top I just think it's
weird that Bill Gates is buying the most
farmland
out of everyone
um why does he want all of that he wants
to control the food that's why we need
to grow on food and have seven kids
completely agree at the same time too
he's saying that eggs are bad for you he
he's trying to be a health expert and
he's just overweight he's out of shape
he's saying eggs are bad he's saying
don't even look at him just look at his
face do you really want to take Health
advice from someone who looks like that
people like him are saying trust the
science and he's not even a scientist
and he has no medical background he's
going to tell us about Jabs a red letter
we're just gonna read it we're cooking
don't go anywhere don't go anywhere I
would like to go on another day with you
if I could have the honor okay okay of
speaking to you more I would love to
keep talking to you of course can you
set your name one more time Nazarene
nazarin yeah I'm snico sneaker it was
great to meet you you too nice to meet
you can I have a hug yeah I just oh
there's another one out there
I mean yeah there aren't many of us but
they can be found for sure
[Music]
I'm ready to start a family with her
I was there like another room in here
that we could just I want to get her
pregnant right now
I'm ready I will give her seven kids
everything she says I like and the way
she dressed the way she just
I think she lapped up the I remember the
wokie that I was like I'm gonna change
her bro what the hell am I talking about
why am I gonna fix a girl when there's a
girl that already makes sense
and she just
ha I actually yo let me get her number
for real I knew that you thought he was
cheating and he called you crazy yep
because yeah I've done that you've done
that
women are insane this is why women are
crazy I'm literally older than you and
you're calling me a baby
you have the exact same expectation and
standard it's just seen as normal